Hey everyone, Ryan here and welcome back to our oral medicine series.
This video will be about COPD and asthma.
These are two of the main pulmonary diseases that appear on the board exam.
So COPD stands for chronic obstructive pulmonary disease, chronic referring to the fact that
it's long term actually causes irreversible damage, obstructive meaning blocking pulmonary
referring to airflow.
So altogether, it's the term for a preventable respiratory disorder that involves the restriction
of airflow that is not fully reversible.
It's currently the third leading cause of death in the United States and the most common
cause for it is cigarette smoking.
So there are two main clinical manifestations of this disorder.
On the left, we have chronic bronchitis and on the right, we have emphysema.
So chronic bronchitis is all about chronic inflammation in the airways.
So cigarette smoke or environmental pollutants irritate the bronchial walls and increase the
size of mucus glands and goblet cells.
So this causes lots and lots of mucus production on top of the airways getting inflamed and
narrowed.
So it's a lot harder for that patient to breathe both in and out.
So the classic chronic bronchitis patient is known as a blue bloater.
And they have this chronic productive cough with lots of sputum.
They have a noisy chest with ronkai, which refers to this rattling sound and also they
might have some wheezing sounds.
The chest extra actually appears normal, but they have elevated hemoglobin, peripheral edema,
and the patients tend to be cyanotic with blue skin and overweight, hence the blue bloater
moniker.
Now on the right, we have emphysema, which involves only the alveoli or the air sacs,
which are the functional units of the lung distal to or after the terminal bronchioles.
So chronic smoke inhalation damages the lung epithelium, releasing these inflammatory mediators
and enzymes like elastase that end up destroying lung tissue, resulting in these enlarged air
spaces or enlarged alveoli.
So they also lose elastic recoil as a result of these enzymes like elastase.
So this makes breathing a lot more difficult, specifically breathing out or expiration.
So how you can remember this, whereas chronic bronchitis affects both inspiration and expiration.
Emphysema affects more expiration, so E for emphysema, E for expiration.
The classic emphysema patient is known as a pink puffer.
So they usually don't have a cough or much sputum, and they have a pretty quiet chest,
no ronkai or wheezing.
However, their chest is often barrel shaped with these over-inflated lungs due to the
trapping of air, because they really struggle to expiry that air.
So as a result, the diaphragm is usually flattened, and the heart is usually smaller, because
it's squished between those oversized lungs.
And then the puffer part comes from having smoked for a long period of time.
So pink puffers tend to be old, thin, and have severe dyspnea or trouble breathing.
Now most patients with COPD may exhibit features of both of these diseases, so you could fall
into one category or the other, or you could exhibit symptoms and signs from both of these
unique categories.
So how about diagnosis of COPD?
Well we have a couple of methods.
The spirometer is used to measure the amount of air that a person can breathe out.
So how this works is the patient would take a deep breath and blow into this tube as hard
as possible with a clip on their nose, so all the air is being released through the mouth.
And it's hooked up to a machine that records the results.
And so the forced expiry volume in one second, that's FEV1, that is less than 70% the predicted
volume called the forced vital capacity, or FVC for short, in the absence of any other
pulmonary disease is given a COPD diagnosis.
Now depending on the severity, COPD is labeled anywhere from stage one for mild to stage
four for very severe.
We can also do pulse oximetry, so pulse oximeter is a lot easier to do, and it measures the
oxygen saturation or the percentage of hemoglobin saturated with oxygen in the arterial blood.
So it isn't used to diagnose COPD, but it can be used to supplement a diagnosis, or in
our case, help determine the patient's current health status and the pulmonary function
while in the dental chair.
So the spirometer is something that a medical professional would be involved in to diagnose
the patient.
The pulse oximeter is just something that we could use in the dental chair to monitor
their current status.
Mental blood gas measurement and chest radiographs can also aid in the diagnosis of COPD.
Now although COPD is irreversible, medications can be used in order to slow the progression
or at least manage the disease.
So inhaled anticholinergics are considered bronchodilators, and they function to reduce
mucous secretion in the airways and relax smooth muscle in order to open up the airways
by blocking acetylcholine at the muscarinic receptors.
So some examples would be iprotropium and teotropium, the tropiums.
Now next we have the inhaled beta adrenergic agonists, and these are also called bronchodilators.
These are also considered bronchodilators, and they function to relax smooth muscle of
the airways by increasing cyclic AMP levels.
Some are fast acting like epinephrine, while others are longer acting like endocateral.
Combining these two categories can have significant benefits because they work by different mechanisms
but they work to achieve the same outcome.
They both function to open the airways essentially and make breathing easier for the COPD patients.
Corticosteroids work by reducing inflammation and suppressing the immune response.
Some examples are fluticazone, which is an inhaled drug and prednisone, which is an
oral medication.
And lastly we have the phosphodiesterase inhibitors, like theophiline, as sort of a
last resort, this medication can have some side effects that are not so fun.
Now I like these drug categories because they're as easy to remember as A, B, C, D.
And so that's how I tend to remember these drug categories.
And one possible management strategy is to start with an anticholinergic for stage 1
COPD and then adding a long-acting bronchodilator if that patient's stage 2, adding a corticosteroid
to the mix if they're stage 3, and then using theophiline as a last resort for stage 4,
very severe COPD.
So not only do we have this order, A, B, C, D, but it also tends to be the order in which
those drugs are prescribed for COPD patients.
So a nice little memory tip to help you remember those drug categories.
Next let's talk about some considerations for COPD patients that are in the dental chair.
So smoking cessation is the most effective and cost-effective intervention that can help
manage COPD, so we want to encourage that for patients who are actively smoking.
Some innervational therapies include things like nicotine replacement and bupropion therapy.
We want to avoid pulmonary irritants, so excellent isolation and suction is really useful for
these types of patients.
Patients with moderate to severe COPD should be placed in a semisupine or upright chair
position instead of a supine position to help prevent difficulty breathing and discomfort
for the patient.
Bilateral mandibular blocks or bilateral greater palatine blocks can cause an unpleasant airway
constriction feeling in some of these patients, so that should be avoided whenever possible.
Rubber dams can also constrict breathing ability for patients with severe disease, so avoid
those also when possible.
We certainly want to avoid narcotics and barbiturates because they are respiratory depressants and
we do not want to be depressing pulmonary function.
We want to avoid macrolide antibiotics like erythromycin and also siprofloxacin if the
patient is taking theofiline because these antibiotics can reduce the metabolism of theofiline
resulting in theofiline toxicity which may involve things like nausea, vomiting, insomnia,
headache, arrhythmia and even convulsions.
A pulse oximeter should be used to monitor oxygen saturation throughout the dental procedure.
Nitrous oxide inhalation generally should not be used for severe COPD patients because nitrous
oxide might accumulate in the air spaces of the compromised lung.
Low flow oxygen at a rate of 2 liters per minute is recommended if a person's oxygen
saturation is below 95%.
In general anesthesia is not recommended for COPD patients for airway concerns.
Lastly, if the patients taking systemic corticosteroids for COPD, they might require supplementation
for major surgical procedures due to the concern for adrenal suppression.
This is a consideration for anyone who takes corticosteroids chronically and we'll talk
more about that in the next video in this series.
Now for a poorly controlled or unstable COPD patient, this is somebody who's symptomatic
with shortness of breath at rest, productive cough, upper respiratory infection or an oxygen
saturation that's below 91%.
Those are things that we're considering unstable.
And that type of patient should be rescheduled and the appropriate medical referral should
be made.
It's what I call defer and refer.
So as in the past, if the patient needs emergency care, you can consider some conservative treatment
or a hospital referral depending on the presence or absence of symptoms, your own emergency
preparedness and a multitude of other factors.
But for the board exam, if a situation is unstable, it's uncontrolled, it's symptomatic,
then we want to refer for medical consultation.
Now also for a COPD patient, we want to look out for cardiovascular comorbidities which
are very common in COPD patients and then follow those patient considerations when necessary.
As far as oral manifestations of COPD, we see things like halitosis, staining of the teeth,
nicotine stomatitis, periodontal disease and oral cancer that are related to smoking because
the vast majority of these patients are going to be chronic smokers.
Poor oral hygiene might lead to aspiration pneumonia in these patients.
The pneumonia is an infection of the lungs and/or airways and aspiration pneumonia occurs when
something containing bacteria like food or even saliva is breathed into the lungs or
airways leading to this pneumonia.
Dry mouth is something we see in a lot of these conditions that we've talked about so
far in the series, but in this case specifically, it's due to the side effects of the anti-colonergic
medications, those tropiums.
And then Steven Johnson syndrome has been linked to theophiling use.
All right, so the second half of this video is going to be about asthma.
Asthma is also a chronic respiratory disease associated with airway obstruction, but this
one is characterized by reversible episodes of increased airway responsiveness that leads
to episodes of breathing difficulty, coughing, or wheezing.
And the broccular tissue is sensitive to several stimuli, and there are many things that can
trigger an asthma attack or flare up, it could be, an allergen like pollen, an upper respiratory
infection, exercise, cold air, NSAIDs, chemicals, smoke, and even anxiety and stress.
And one of the first things you should ask an asthmatic patient is what triggers their
attacks, and then make sure to avoid those things in the dental setting as much as possible.
As far as pathophysiology for this one, airway obstruction can be the result of many different
things.
It could be smooth muscle spasm, inflammation of the bronchial mucosa, and/or goblet cell
hyperplasia, that means too many goblet cells, which is also seen in chronic bronchitis.
And the excess mucus from these goblet cells would plug up the airways, making this volume
a lot smaller.
And as far as diagnosing, as with COPD, spirometry is the gold standard.
Allergy testing and sputum smears could also be done in addition to that.
So now for asthma medications, there is a lot of overlap with the COPD ones, and I have
another ABCD, but this one comes with some caveats.
So anti-asmatics for asthma management are used either for long-term control or short-term
immediate relief, and the combination of those two is usually used to improve lung function.
And I actually want to start this one with the C, the corticosteroids, because inhaled
corticosteroids are currently the most effective anti-inflammatory medication for treating persistent
asthma.
And similar with COPD, they reduce inflammation.
So some examples are a prednisone, budessinide, and fluticazone.
Now we also have our bronchodilators back once again, these beta-adronergic agonists, and
they activate the beta-2 receptors to relax smooth muscle of the airways just like they
did with COPD.
For an acute asthma attack, the first line of defense is going to be a short-acting bronchodilator,
like albuterol, via an inhaler, or a nebulizer.
You can also pair this with supplemental oxygen via a face mask or nasal hood, and if the
symptoms worsen or do not improve after that, then you would administer epinephrine subcutaneously
and likely activate EMS, aka call 911.
What's cool is that there are combination drugs that combine a corticosteroid with a long-acting
beta-adronergic agonist.
For example, 4-motorol and budessinide combined become cymbicort, or salmetarol, and fluticazone
combined become adver, and you may have heard of those names before, and that's what's
going on with those drugs.
Let's go to our A for antihistamines, and those block the histamine receptor.
Cymbine is an organic compound released by mast cells during degranulation, which happens
when an allergen binds to the IgE, the immunoglobulin E, attached to those mast cells, and histamine
is responsible for three things in the classic allergic response, redness, swelling, and itchiness,
so blocking that with diphenhydramine or benedryl, or phexofenidine, which is a legra, and you
may have heard of those two before, helps to calm the allergic response.
Now, there is an asterisk after antihistamines, because antihistamines are not prescribed
for asthma, they're given for allergies.
But if allergies trigger your asthma, then that's when an antihistamine can be used to
help control asthma and prevent those asthma attacks, so hopefully that makes sense.
Decongestants, or D, do exactly what you'd expect, they reduce nasal congestion.
And pseudo-ephedrin, brand name pseudofed, is an A1 or alpha-1 selective agonist, which
means it's a vasoconstrictor, so it constricts nasal blood vessels, reducing nasal swelling
and inflammation.
It's mostly used to treat cold, flu, allergies, and sinusitis, but once again, if allergies
are the precipitating factor for asthma, it can be used to indirectly manage your asthma.
And lastly, we have leukotrying receptor antagonists, which of course, block leukotrying, which
is a pro-inflammatory mediator that the body releases after coming in contact with an allergen.
And these leukasts are examples of the leukotrying receptor antagonists.
So patient considerations for asthma.
If we see asthma on the patient box, what are things we want to be thinking about?
Well the primary goal is to prevent an acute asthma attack.
That's the last thing that we want in the dental chair.
So we want to avoid any precipitating factors.
So what are those precipitating factors?
Stress and anxiety is one of them.
So we want to reduce stress, be kind and gentle.
Again, explain the procedures, answer their questions, and we also could consider a short-acting
benzodiazepine before the appointment, and we can consider nitrous oxide during the appointment
as long as the patient isn't a symptomatic for asthma at that moment.
They're not actively wheezing or something like that.
We also want to confirm the patient is taking their asthma medication as directed, and we
want to have their rescue inhaler and an EpiPen ready and accessible if they have an attack.
Once again, we want to have excellent isolation to minimize any tooth enamel, dust, or any
other pulmonary irritants that could trigger an episode.
We want to avoid NSAIDs because they have been shown to precipitate asthma attacks in
a small percent of the population.
So that's very, very important to note.
Once again, avoid narcotics and barbiturates because they have respiratory depressive
properties and can also trigger an attack.
We want to track the patient's oxygen saturation.
Once again, valuable information to have.
It should be somewhere between 97% and 100%, and if it drops below that 95% level, then
consider oxygen supplementation, that low-flow oxygen.
And again, I would reschedule, defer, and refer.
If the patient is actively coughing, wheezing, they forgot to take their medication that they
usually do, etc.
Oral manifestations of asthma, the zerostomia, or dry mouth, this time is due to the usage
of inhalers that dry out the mouth, as opposed to the anti-colonergics from COPD, which also
dry out the mouth.
These patients have increased carious risk due to the decreased salivary flow.
Gastroesophageal reflux disease is common in patients with asthma and is exacerbated
by the use of bronchodilators and theophiline.
Oral candidiasis occurs in about 5% of patients who used inhaled corticosteroids for long
periods of time.
Enamel defects have been associated with severe asthma in children, while periodontitis
has been associated with severe asthma in adults.
And asthmatics who are mouth breathers may be associated with higher rates of malocclusion,
specifically excess overjet, posterior crossbite, high palatal vault, and increased face height,
all associated with habitual mouth breathing.
And since we're talking about pulmonary diseases, I wanted to briefly cover indications and
contraindications to both nitrous oxide in this slide and oxygen on the next slide,
the two most used gases in dentistry.
Nitrous oxide can be helpful for someone with dental anxiety, a strong gag reflex, and what
we just talked about, asthma.
And since nitrous oxide is not irritating to the trachea and the bronchi, asthma is not
a contraindication to the use of nitrous oxide, provided the patient is not having an attack
or wheezing at that moment.
So poorly controlled asthma we defer and refer, but otherwise nitrous is totally fine.
But in fact, there's a benefit in administering nitrous oxide, since in many asthmatics, the
primary precipitate is usually emotional stress, especially in children.
So you could see how nitrous oxide could actually help prevent us from having an attack in the
chair.
Now there are a lot of contraindications, most of which are relative, not absolute contraindications,
but I still want to mention them so you're aware of them when it's time for you to sit
for your board exam.
So patients with COPD have a reduced ability to move gases into and out of the lungs.
We talked about that at the very beginning of this video.
Therefore, it's more difficult to administer nitrous oxide, and more importantly, is more
difficult to get it out of the patient's lungs.
While it can be used in mild to moderate cases, severe COPD patients have a respiratory drive
triggered by decreased oxygen levels, as opposed to a healthy patient whose drive to breathe
is triggered by increased carbon dioxide levels.
So what that means is administering nitrous oxide, which is always given alongside lots
of oxygen, can actually decrease the patient's drive to breathe, which is potentially very,
very dangerous for a severe COPD patient.
So we could put a little asterisk here.
It's not.
And for mild to moderate COPD patients, it's okay.
But once we get to that severe and above level, we really want to try to avoid nitrous
oxide for those patients.
Nasal obstruction.
So since nitrous oxide must be administered through a nasal mask, this is a relative
contraindication depending on how severe the obstruction is.
Even habitual mouth breathers may have difficulty using the nasal mask.
Multiple sclerosis involves nerve de-biolination, especially in the central nervous system.
And leads to weakness, poor muscle coordination, speech disturbances among other neurological
disturbances.
And chronic use of nitrous oxide can produce similar symptoms.
So it's not recommended to use nitrous oxide chronically in these patients.
One or two times is perfectly fine, though.
Pregnancy.
This is an important one.
Nitrous oxide readily enters fetal circulation, and it can be toxic to cells undergoing
mitosis.
So pregnant patients should avoid nitrous oxide, especially when they are early on in
their pregnancy.
Psychiatric disorders are often managed with prescribed medications, but they can be difficult
to manage.
It's probably a good idea to consult the patient's psychiatrist before administering nitrous
oxide because their reaction to inhalation sedation could be unpredictable.
All with that, communication barriers are important because much of the monitoring of
a patient's conscious sedation with nitrous oxide is done verbally to make sure it's working
properly.
You're checking in with the patient, checking to see how they're feeling, and confirming
with the patient that they're at the right stage of sedation.
So having a language barrier could be a potential problem.
Otitis media.
So nitrous oxide should be avoided in children with a middle ear infection.
That's what otitis media is, because of concerns about pressure buildup and gas diffusion.
And lastly, sickle cell disease.
So regular use of nitrous oxide can actually interfere with vitamin B12 metabolism, which
is a problem because these patients, the sickle cell patients, have a B12 deficiency
already.
All right.
And lastly, let's talk about a couple indications and contraindications for oxygen use.
So in the yes column, we have COPD and asthma, the two main diseases we talked about.
And humidified low flow oxygen can be provided to COPD patients safely to help alleviate an
unpleasant airway.
And oxygen is also safe and sometimes indicated for asthma patients.
We talked about this and those patient consideration slides for both COPD and asthma.
So that makes perfect sense.
I want to be clear that once again, there are no absolute contraindications to oxygen,
but it should be administered with caution in two specific scenarios.
And that's for patients who have taken or are currently taking bleomycin, which is a
chemotherapeutic agent that can damage the lungs and patients who are suffering from
paraquat poisoning, which is a toxic herbicide.
And since oxygen is administered alongside nitrous oxide when doing inhalation sedation,
these two things would also be contraindications to nitrous oxide sedation as well.
All right.
So that's it for this video guys.
Thank you so much for watching, please like this video if you enjoyed it and subscribe
to this channel for much more on dentistry.
If you'd like to support me, please check out my Patreon page and thank you to all of
my patrons here for their support.
You can unlock access to my video slides to take notes on and practice questions for
the board exams.
So go check that out.
The link will be in the description.
Thanks again for watching everyone.
I'll see you in the next video.